How do you handle it when someone up the chain of command beat trees trust,
like what is this like lying they lie to you or this could be, this is a huge,
this is a huge spectrum of things I guess. Yeah. So for,
for number one you just learned, right?
You just learned something about someone's character. Yeah.
You now kind of know better what you're dealing with. Now,
if this is a major situation,
you might have to immediately confronted and or go above them and the chain of
command, I mean, if there's lives at risk,
if there's something morally wrong that is happening,
if there's something he illegal that's happening that now you're going to get
wrapped into, and that's another decision you gotta make.
If you're not going to be wrapped into it,
then it's a decision you've got to make.
If you want to ruin this person's life or whatever, that's,
that's a different decision. That's not this question.
We'd have to deal with that in a separate question. Hmm.
Are innocent people being hurt? So if, if it's something like that,
lives at risk, you know, something morally wrong is happening,
something illegal is happening, innocent people being hurt,
then you're probably going to have to say something or you're going to have to
say something. Now, I will tell you this before you say something,
make sure all your ducks in a row, make sure you have evidence.
Don't go off half cocked. Be Ready.
Because people that are deceitful like this, they, they, they prepare,
they are ready for battle, um,
to protect themselves and they don't care what happens to other people.
So you've got to watch out for that. Now if it's something really,
if it's something minor, you know, if it's something minor,
then that's something that you logged down and in the brain,
right? And something that you logged down in the brain. And,
um,
but it allows you to see person's character. And that means, again,
it's a minor infraction,
but it also means you got to watch yourself and you're gonna Watch them a little
bit more closely. [inaudible] you gotta be careful because people like that,
they think they're smarter than everyone else. Yeah.
The thing that they're getting away with lies.
So they think they're smarter than, there's like a little hint of sociopath.
Yeah. In there that they can get away with these lies.
And so you gotta watch them. You gotta watch them
carefully in, like I said, it Kinda goes back to that previous question
because you don't want to be a person that comes across as dishonest yourself.
And if people don't think they can trust what you're saying,
they're not going to trust you with other things. So if you know,
I'm not giving you good feedback because I'm too nice,
you're not going to start you. You're not going to respect my opinion anymore.
Right. So you know when you're,
when you're dealing with someone, if someone comes to you and said, again,
this is honesty versus dishonesty. If you come to me and say, Hey,
what do you think of this plan? I'm not going to say, Hey,
I think that's a stupid plan.
Okay.
I might say, I don't know if that's how I do it. I might try this approach.
Right? You're just going to be diplomatic. If you,
if I'm not going to say to you,
and I don't think you're smart enough to figure this out,
I want to move you to a different division cause I don't think you're smart
enough to solve this problem. I'm not going to say that. I'm going to say,
you know what?
I need you on this other project over here that I think you're going to be
really knocked this thing out of the park.
Mm.
Now you're getting to know deep inside,
okay,
but it's called tact and that's what you have to use.
But back to the honesty, or we person betrays your trust. You've learned,
you've learned about their character.
If it's a big thing you're going to have to talk about,
are going to have to tell somebody. Yeah. It's a little thing
you got to watch.